[拍手]
私は都市部に住み電気メーカーで商品
デザインをしていました
大量生産のものづくりは人の生活を豊かに
しました
でも環境はどんどん悪化しています
工業でデザイナーとしてものづくりは
大好きだけど
環境はどんどん悪くさせている
そんなジレンマを抱えながらデザインの
仕事をしていました
デザインとは一体誰のためにあるの
でしょうか
私は二十歳の時に渡米しサンフランシスコ
でヒューマンセンターアドデザインを学び
ました
ヒューマンセンターのデザインとは
テクノロジーを中心にものづくりをするの
ではなく人を中心に置き
課題やニーズを理解しそれを解決する
デザインの手法です
帰国後日本のヘルスケア企業に入り
人の
健康課題を解決するためのプロダクトのや
アプリのデザインディレクションを手掛け
てきました
例えば高齢出産の増えてくる中
ホルモンバランスを整えるための婦人体温
計です
私は課題解決型のデザインに
夢中になりました
働きながら自然豊かな場所で子育てがし
たい
と思い
京都の北の県北エリアで
江戸中期に建てられた
茅葺き古民家に住み始めました
ここから車で約1時間ぐらいの場所です
初めはこんな美しい場所に住めるなんてと
日本昔ばなしの世界に住んでいるような
そんな気持ちでいっぱいでした
まだ茅葺きのメンテナンスのこととか
分かってなかったんですね
しばらくすると地域の室町時代から代々
茅葺き古民家に住むオーナーさんから
ちゃんと早かって屋根裏にためなあかん
でって
怒られたんですね
そうなんです
茅葺き屋根は20年から25年に1度
吹き替えがあります
それまでに毎年会を貯めていかないといけ
ないん
です私たちは地域の
萱場を共有してもらうことになりました
ここがそのカヤバです
毎年11月になると家族で萱刈りをします
手入れのイカヤバは春に地面に日光が
たくさん当たるので多様な草花が咲き
わらびを取ることもできます
夏になって会話が伸びてくるとこんなに
可愛いカヤネズミが
姿を現します
カヨネズミはボール状の巣を作るんですね
このカヤボールがたくさんある萱場は
茅としての
素材としてもすごくいい替刃だと言われて
います
スズキは田舎なので
藁と同じように
納豆菌がいますわかりますよねわらずと
納豆とかちょっと想像していただけたら
いいかなと思うんですけれども
藁と同じようにですね納豆菌がいて
茅葺きの古民家というのは
金とともに住む
暮らしていくそんな家になります
長い囲炉裏で許された
古い茅葺きは
粉砕されて
田んぼの肥やしになります
常在菌がたくさんついた蚊帳はすごくいい
肥やしになります
お気づきでしょうか
茅葺き科学の建築デザインは人ではなく
循環が中心になっています
里山にはこのような循環を中心に置いた
暮らしがたくさんあります
例えば養鶏です
県北地域では近所の方から鶏がいただけ
ます
でその鶏の卵をいただき私たちの食べた
野菜くず食べ残しを鶏が食べます
卵を孵化して
鶏のひよこを育てて親鳥を食べます
子供は
鶏に餌をあげるのが大好きです
自分たちの食べ残しを捨てずに生き物に餌
を与える
循環する暮らしは何か人間の
根源的な幸せを感じさせてくれ
ますこうした暮らしの中で継承されてきた
人間の営みこそ次のデザインのヒントが
あると感じていき始めました
そこで
里山の知恵を世界につなげる
というコンセプトで7カ国語の言語を語る
中山慶都共に会社を立ち上げました
この会社は世界中の大学生やクリエイター
たちに
里山の知恵に触れてもらい次のデザインを
共に考える国際教育プログラムを提供して
います
地域には代々受け継がれてきた知恵があり
ます
林業化
茅葺き職人など私たちは彼らを知恵の伝承
者
ローカルウィスダムマイスターと呼び彼ら
を先生として
研修クラブを作っています
例えばこれは日本の
循環型の建築デザインを学びたいと
イタリアの家具職人や建築デザイナーの
方たちが刑法に来てくれました
茅葺きを一緒に拭いたり
丸太市場で競り市を体験したり
土壁の作り方を学ぶ研修プログラムを行い
ました
イタリア人も京都の職人さんも言葉が通じ
なくても互いの技術知恵が
体で
身体
身体値化しているので体で教え合って
とても深い交流になりました
そんな中パンデミックが起きました地域の
中に外国人を呼べなくなってしまったん
ですね
私たちはこの中でもオンラインで京都の
丹後半島の漁師とフランスの物体に地方の
漁師をつなげて
互いの物産を送り合うフードチャット
イベントを行いました
ブルターニュからはシードルやパテそばの
ウイスキー
端午からはお酒や乾物や発酵食品などを
送り
食べながら互いの海のことを話し合いまし
た
そしたら
丹後半島の漁師さんがいきなりそっちは
オマールエビが取れるっていうけどタコは
大丈夫なの」って聞くんですね
すると向こうのフランスの方の漁師さんが
えなんでタコのことわかるのっていう話に
なったんです
実は
温暖化により南の大凧が北に上がってくる
ということが世界中で起こっているそうな
んです
日本でも函館のカニが食べられる被害が
起きているそうでフランスでも同じ状況に
なっているというんです
ブルターニュではそれを解決しててその
方法を教えるから
研修においでってもう本当にこの場で
漁師さんがフランスに行く研修ツアーが
決まりました
改めて海はつながっているんだなって
すごく思ったんですね
またこの海の知恵を継ぐマイスター同士
ならではというか
課題を解決する問題意識は国境を簡単に
超えてしまう力があると感動しました
このお仕事を通じて分かってきたのは
京都
里山サステナブル
という言葉は世界から見てもとても魅力的
だということです
ある時タイの全国をの側近の方が連絡を
いただきました
全国大が守り続けてきたタイの灰ですね
このはいと呼ばれるバンカちゃんの森を
どうやって維持するべきか考えたい
森の中で国際カンファレンスを行うので
私たちに京都の循環型ツアーの先進事例と
して話をしてほしいと依頼を受けました
タイにもこのようにするするっと木に登っ
てココナッツシュガーを作る
ローカルビスダムマイスターがいるのです
が日本と同じように軽症者がいない状況
です
今まで注目されてこなかった地域の技こそ
が世界の人が注目する
魅力になる
その技をどう次の時代に継承するのか
経済と自然のバランスのいいビジネスの
デザインのあり方など話し合いました
これからの社会を考えたときにデザインは
一体誰のためにあるべきものでしょうか
私は自然循環を促すため地球のためにある
べきだと思います
これからは資本主義経済ではなく自然主義
経済を考える必要があります
そしてそのヒントは地域が継承してきた
人々の知恵にあります
世界中の知恵がつながりそこで起きる深い
学びに次のデザインの大きな可能性を感じ
ています
ご清聴ありがとうございまし
た